so all right we've whittled it down that
the big problems here are there's a
little bit of traffic and a salmon
avocado roll could be hard to come by so
i think it's doing all right uh but
obviously all of this has a little
something to do with the guy that's been
in charge for the last couple years uh
we all had the pleasure of having dinner
at the governor's mansion with ron
desantis about a month and a half ago
totally open it was off the record
conversation so we're not going to
repeat anything that was said but just
struck me as just like a really really
decent guy who does not want to be king
that was my main takeaway of the night
like he does not want to rule over
people he'd like people to be free we
could have pulled a gajillion clips of
him doing it right over the last two
years we've got this one on
children and masks and mandates take a
look these kids are so much happier
being able to go to school without
having to wear masks for eight hours a
day so when you start to see them kind
of re-evaluate or say all this just
understand this the science didn't
change well the medical science didn't
change
the political science change they feel
the heat they know that voters have been
tired of perpetual lockdown policies
they know that they have basically
offered no off ramp and and they know
that they're fixed and to get whooped at
the polls and so that's what's causing
the epiphany but the fact of the matter
is if they had looked at the actual
science from the beginning
they would have known that this was
something that florida was right on
carol let me start with you on that one
because you basically moved here for
your kids as we talked about a second
ago um can you just talk about you know
having them out of the masks be free
just their general state i read a study
yesterday or the day before about the
speech issues that kids are now having
because literally their mouth muscles
are not developing the way they are
supposed to and they can't see the
teacher's mouths so they can't mimic
things and it's going to delay speech
for years
that is it's just like anybody who's
ever met a child knew that was going to
happen like i i don't understand how
that's even like news you know but so
many people were ringing that alarm for
so long and we were obviously all
dismissed but you know about the
governor like i feel very defensive of
him i i do get into like arguments all
the time on his behalf and
it is not because i like him as a
politician although yes i do um it's
because i feel like he he stands up for
literally me like for me for my family i
feel like he's actually in the fight
like to help us specifically i i don't i
really can't think of a situation where
i felt that way before like the only
like even comparable thing to me is like
how much i credited rudy giuliani uh
with turning new york city around and
how i felt like that made a real
tangible difference in my life that i
could ride the subway at night or you
know any number of things and this is
like the only time in my life where i
think a politician has had such a direct
effect on what happens in my life and on
behalf of my children that i just feel
like i have to constantly go to back for
him because he is protecting me and i
think i i owe him the same kind of
protection and it's it's as a
constituent not as a journalist i i feel
very strongly for him as a
constitutional yeah i i feel the same
way john when we were talking to him and
again we can't say anything that that
was private not not that we said
anything that shouldn't have been said
publicly but that was just the nature of
the of the dinner um the thing that
really struck me was how
he kind of was just like yeah i just
didn't feel that i should listen to
group think and i should do what i
thought was right like that's kind of
how i want to lead that in essence was
was it
like that's pretty freaking special
these days huh
yeah and i love that carol waited ron de
santa giuliani because i say this often
on social media
those are two guys who hate politicians
and if you hate politicians you're a
good politician i've always said the
next the next republican president who
comes in that's conservative should find
a
a pool of people who hate doj fbi cia
nsa and whoever that pool hates those
agencies the most there's your secretary
there's your director and i think a guy
like desantis hates bureaucracy i you
know i've been around his team and him
for many years operating politically
down here in florida and they are they
aren't just a political they're
anti-political in fact i had a
conversation that night with his chief
of staff and and uh it's something
he said very publicly ron desantis isn't
beholden to polls he doesn't make
decisions based on polling he makes them
based on science and what's best for the
people of the state of florida his
constituents or when he was a
congressman his congressional district
we need more like that and carol's
hunters are right he is an act for
dave you've been i think it's i think
it's interesting that
the four of us now lived in
you know all four of us here lived in
new york city under giuliani
and all of us you know are obviously
here under desantis and and that
parallel that that you know carol and
and and and john mentioned was
absolutely apt
um you know there's no better
uh you know there's no better analog for
it in uh in in american politics
certainly
not you know in in any city so the
million-dollar question that everybody's
asking is you know is he gonna run for
president and i hate doing too much i
like just like the racehorse politics
kind of thing but i've been very clear
about this a couple times on the show
and on twitter i don't want him to run
for president i think the governor
matters way more i would like to keep
this state right let's keep modeling
this thing right you know he's only been
governor for a couple of years it's not
even like he's been doing this for that
long it's like let's keep this right i
also think biden is so damaged
that whether it's trump or whoever it's
like there's a really good chance and
and obviously the midterms seem like
they're gonna make some sense or at
least you know push some of this wave of
insanity back a bit